decision and i think he was right uh
it's a tragedy for him
it's a great loss for parliament he is a
man of great integrity a great
experience
uh he's a delightful person we were in
cabinet together i know him well
and only for many years and he's also
very clever this was uh
uh an error of judgment as he has
conceded
and it is
very sad i mean he hasn't done anything
illegal he hasn't done anything which is
technically wrong but he was clearly an
error of judgment well yes and it's
still being looked at isn't it he does
deny wrongdoing as you say he says he
may have made errors of judgment but do
you think he's damaged the party at all
i don't think he's damaged the party i
think that and we've had jack straw also
caught in the same
uh sting
uh so it's this is not a matter of party
politics one way or another but it is
very sad well yes and whether ultimately
found not to have broken any rules would
you agree that it looks bad when you see
some arkham saying things like he had
lots of time on his hands he described
himself as self-employed he says no one
pays me a salary that kind of thing
doesn't look good does it no it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't look good and i
think he recognizes that but it is still
very sad but uh having time on his hands
i mean that is absolutely true i mean
being
a
member of parliament a constituency
member of parliament although it's an
important job
is not a full-time job and indeed the
proof of that is that ministers are
also
members of parliament they do both jobs
when i was chance of the exchequer i had
one of the heaviest
workloads in the country and yet i
continued as a constituency member and i
don't think anybody said i wasn't doing
my job there so
you do if you're just a constituency
member uh have time on your hands and if
you do use that
in order to further your experience of
the world that's good for parliament
people complain about the westminster
hot house so you want people who are in
contact with the real world but he was a
chairman of a very important committee
considering very important issues about
national security yes and that's why it
was an area of judgment what's your stat
what's your stand on whether or not mps
should have other sources of income do
you think that that is part of the issue
here i i think it's i i think it's a
thoughtfully from the parliament issue
it's an irrelevance and it shouldn't be
brought in
uh the the different countries have
different uh views in france where i
live if you a member of parliament is
appointed to be a minister he has to
resign as member of parliament devote
himself full-time as a minister because
they think a minister has to be
full-time we don't take that view and i
think you need to look at is we think
that it is good for a minister to be in
touch with the real world to be in touch
with the people to look after the people
in his own constituency that makes him a
better minister and so
and in the same way it is good for
members of the parliament if they wish
to to to be active in what you might
call the real world but don't you think
many members of the public expect their
mps to do a full-time job especially
when they're getting a salary of sixty
seven thousand pounds that's not the
point they expect them to do a good job
and i'm sure malcolm rifkind always did
a very good job and most members of
parliament and you can go up and down
the country and you'll find constituents
who know them know this most members of
parliament do a very good job